je veux apporter la photo bien sûr même
apporter une photo mais pas de votre vie
si vous voulez hein c'est mignon mais
chez nous elle me bat si c'est vrai ah
oui tous les matthieu delormeau savoir
mathieu tu m'entends bon mathieu comment
sa maman chérie je vous reçois bourgeois
ah bon mon mathieu il ya une de ses plus
grandes fans qui s'appelle alexandra à
qui tu vas faire un toc toc toc a fait
partie de thé de leurs moeurs
tu va taper à sa porte je pense que
peut-être que maintenant si elle nous
regarde
elle doit savoir que c'est toi mais ça
va quand même une surprise énorme pour
elles alors la petite sur le canapé avec
un bon dos pour l'instant parce que ses
parents en fait exprès qu'elle ne voit
pas la télé
bonsoir
alors à la petite alexandra elle et elle
sait pas qui a battu pour l'instant ça
va être une énorme surprise pour elle
regarder parce que ses parents ont tout
fait pour qu'elle ne sache pas bien
mathieu qui est avec elle
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il est j'ai trouvé tout c'est
vrai enfin le fan art
enfin une bonne base sérieuse
mon coeur est mignonne mais c'est
vraiment ses moyens blague mais bref des
quotas c'est trop mignon
tu avais vous tapez où ceux-ci bouffe
sur nrj tu avais vus c'était moi tu
avais plus tard alors les sur les
méridiens sur nrj12 aux sarthois
c'est vrai je suis un petit peu tous les
deux mais c'est trop mignon
selectrip qu'est ce que tu aimes c'est
moi le quai le charisme c'est drôle vrai
ouais non fallait les animaux tous les
deux bien sûr même apporter une photo
mais pas de votre ville si vous voulez
un est mignon vivait chez nous elle me
bat si c'est vrai allez tous les
[Applaudissements]
accor
idem quand même battu rejeter mais
mathieu que tu es fier de toi
mathieu
[Rires]
[Musique]